yeah i got something for the fox man you
know for looking out for me for speaking
up for me putting me in this motion
picture i wanted to gift him with
something special so fox
welcome to the family man you got to be
kidding me man
you got to be kidding me man this bet
not be what i think it is because i saw
everybody else getting one i didn't want
to say nothing in the interview like
damn
the death row chain man
the death row chain man rose gold and
let me tell you why that's so
significant i watched this man as a
young artist
sometimes have to fight for his life
and he was giving everybody
anthems and songs while we were partying
and dancing sometimes he come to the
career be like
i don't know
so for this day to come to here for us
to see him bloom
is special to see him in kicking ass in
this movie as a as an actor and at the
same time anybody can tell you snoop is
the ambassador of grace entertainment
and fun anytime you say snoop doggy dog
your soul lights up so for this moment
right here
it means everything my dude
that's everything and it's queen by by
side at the same time hey man let me
tell you something this is what it's
about
and august 12th
friday netflix don't share that password
[Laughter]
don't you share that password thank you
man
thank you
who was that to do something like that
for jamie man come on man that's jamie
foxx man the one and only we've been
friends for a long time so for us to
both be at this part of our career to
where we can work together and still
enjoy each other's company you know
that's what it's all about what is it
like watching your family now grow in
this business i see cordell look at this
superstar over here look at this dude
right here a daggone movie star right
can you believe it
what is it like watching them all grow
and your husband turning into an action
hero it's a beautiful thing to see my
family bloom this way it's so beautiful
the kids husband
it's beautiful i'm so proud yeah all
right snoop you killed a bunch of
vampires in this but we also got to talk
about music you've been in the studio
with dre what are y'all cooking up
um we're cooking up a little something
i'm gonna have you come by and do a
little sneak peek i don't want to talk
about it too much but we back together
again it's been 30 years since we worked
on a record and um
we're doing some we're working on
something and then bts i mean you're
everywhere
and you're with bts
too i just try to stay active you know
the youngsters they always reach out and
call me you know the producer benny
blanco reached out the group wanted me
to be a part of that record so you know
i'm about music one thing about me i
don't like being boxed in i like being a
part of everybody's in every genre of
music so when they reach out and call i
usually say yeah